merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre votre co notre réponse n'ayant
commun que personne je repose la
question car nous sommes très nombreux à
nous interroger sur cette nouvelle
fantaisie suggéré par le gouvernement au
travers de la circulaire sur le nuance
âge signé de votre main depuis bientôt
trois ans vous nous affirmer comme
préoccupation principale sur la clarté
et la transparence
et voilà que vous décrétez sans aucune
consultation que seuls les résultats des
communes de plus de 9000 habitants
seront pris en compte dans les résultats
nationaux par partie excluant ainsi 96%
des communes françaises du calcul et 54%
des électeurs
gomez entre 54 % d'un résultat pour un
calcul final il me semble qu'en france
cela ne s'est jamais vu et cerise sur le
gâteau vous créez une nouvelle nuance
dit divergentes qui intégrera doute
liste soutenue par la république en
marche lui dei et le modem
même si la tête de liste et emme est
investi par un autre parti c'est
incroyable
ainsi vous modifier la réalité du
terrain et camoufler la réalité entité
des listes devant de telles incohérences
pourriez-vous une nouvelle fois nous
apporter des réponses claires et
précises pour justifier la perte génial
de cette nouvelle circulaire